The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
SE BAEK OH: So today's class,
we are going to talk about--
called coherence.
And basically Fourier system
with incoherent imaging.
So particularly, this
topic is very important
if you want to take our optics
course because We're dealing
with coherence and incoherence.
So far, we have dealt
with the Fourier system
with a coherent illumination.
Basically, laser light
from a point source--
I mean, pinhole.
So the coherent plane waves
illuminating the Fourier
system, and the frequency
content appears at the plane.
And you can put the
[INAUDIBLE] mask
to play with the
spatial filtering,
and you're going to get some
image at the alpha plane.
But in everyday life, if
you use your digital camera,
you're not using the
really laser illumination.
You mostly use this ambient
light, or if it's too dark,
then you're going to
use the flashlight.
So today, we are going to talk
about more realistic case.
We use the incoherent light.
By the way, the difference
between coherent and incoherent
is basically, you can
make the interference
with the coherent light.
So if you're not
make interference--
you're using laser,
but in most case,
like this white
light source, you're
not going to see interference.
So we're going to first
define what coherence is.
And actually,
there are two kinds
of coherence, temporal
coherence and spatial coherence.
And the rest of the topic
is pretty straightforward.
We will define incoherent point
spread function and its Fourier
transform which is
optical transfer function
and modulation transfer
function, which
is modulus of OTF.
And we're going to
see what MTF means.
And we want to
compare the difference
between spatially coherent
and incoherent images.
So as I just described,
the coherence
is basically ability
to make interference.
So if you have incoherent light,
you cannot make interference.
And if you have
coherent light, then you
can make the interference.
And I'm going to describe it
later, but mathematically--
actually, the
coherence is nothing
but the correlation of wave at
two time space points, which
means we have some light, and
you just sample two points.
It could be different time
points, but you combine them.
And if you see interference,
then you can say it's coherent.
But if you don't
see interference,
then it is incoherent.
So first, let me
describe what's going
to happen if I use the
incoherent light in Michelson
interferometer.
So here, we have the
Michelson interferometer.
So from the point
source, the light--
oops-- is coming in this
direction, this direction.
And at the beam splitter,
half of the light
just transmit the beam
splitter, but the other half
is reflected.
So this path gets reflected
again at the mirror,
and passed through
the beam splitter,
and arrives at the detector.
And the other path is
reflected again, and reflected
at the beam splitter.
And again you get--
I mean, it arrives
at the detector.
So let's just suppose that we
have the laser source here.
Then what you're going
to see at the detector
is a nice sinusoidal pattern
if I move one of the mirror.
Because I can tune the optical
path length that light travels.
And if the distance
match, then I
get the constructive
interference.
And if the phase delay pi, then
I get disruptive interference.
So as I move the
one with the mirror,
I get nice sinusoidal pattern
with the full contrast.
And next, let's suppose
instead of the laser,
I have incoherent
source, which means--
so the horizontal axis is
time, and the vertical axis
is amplitude.
But the phase or amplitude
is varying randomly.
So over time, the amplitudes
are varying randomly.
And even though it's
random, this wave train
will travel through
the interferometer.
So in this path, the
optical path length
is actually constant, which is--
I mean, these paths,
they're common in two path.
So constants plus 2d1
over c, which is time--
speed of light.
And in the second
path, I have the same--
this wave train also travels.
But due to the difference
between d1 and d2,
at the detector,
essentially, I'm
going to sample a
different time point.
So even though it's
random, I basically
choose two time
points here and here,
and combine them
at the detector.
So if the d1 and d2 are
same, then basically,
identical two waves
are coming together,
so I always get
constructive interference.
But what if d1 and
d2 are not same?
And then basically, they
get different phase shift.
And since it's random,
they kind of average out.
So d1 and d2 are getting bigger.
Then basically, the
degree of correlation
is getting decreased, which
means at the detector,
the contrast will
also get decreased.
So if I plot the intensity
at the detector with respect
to d2 minus d1, which is the
distance difference of two
arms, then the intensity
is going to be like this.
So remember that if I have the
laser at point source, then
I will get the sinusoidal
pattern with the full contrast.
But since now I have the
randomly varying source,
this envelop is getting
attenuated like this.
So if I have the rapid
decay curve, which means
I have more incoherent light.
And if I have the
slowly decaying envelop,
then it's more coherent.
And there is another
kind of coherence
which is spatial coherence.
So basically, the
concept is the same,
but we only define the
correlation in space domain.
So now I have the Young
interferometer, which
I have two pinholes, x1 and x2.
And I put a detector at the
center of the two pinholes.
So from this pinhole, we see--
I mean, the spherical wave
is going to be emanating,
but since it is at the center,
these paths are exactly same.
And first, let's suppose
we have laser illumination.
So I have the plane
wave coming in.
Then this spherical wave will
make the Young's interference.
So I'm going to have
the sinusoidal pattern
with the full contrast
at this plane,
but I'm just seeing
at one point.
And again, if I have the
randomly varying wave here--
so in this case, this
horizontal axis amplitude
and vertical axis is
space instead of time.
So this amplitude and phase are
randomly varying over space.
Since I have two
pinholes, so I essentially
sample at two points here
and there, and combine them.
So again, if these two
pinholes are very close,
then these sampling points
are also very close.
So the amplitude and phase
are more likely similar.
[INAUDIBLE]
But if I move these two pinholes
in the upward and downward
like this, then the spacing
between two pinholes
are getting bigger,
and basically, I
lose the correlation,
which means
the spatial coherence is getting
attenuated-- getting smaller.
So again, if I
plot the intensity
at the detector with respect
to x2 minus x1, which
is the spacing
between two pinholes,
then intensity
varying like this.
Again, remember, if
I have the laser,
then it doesn't really matter.
I mean, I always
get a full contrast.
Even though those frequencies--
I mean, [INAUDIBLE] plane-- the
frequency of the interference
is changing.
But I always get
the full contrast,
but contrast getting smaller if
you have the incoherent source.
So let me describe
mathematically
why this happens.
It doesn't really
matter whether I
use the Michelson interferometer
or Young's interferometer.
Basically, interferometer,
we have two waves.
So a1, e to the pi 1,
and a2, d to the pi 2.
Basically, we have two waves I
could sample in space or time
domain.
But anyway, I'm going
to have two waves
and just add them together,
and take the magnitude
square, which is intensity.
So Michelson
interferometer, this is--
I mean, these two waves came
from the different-- the path
length, d1 and d2.
And Young's interferometer,
basically, they
came from the two different
pinholes, x1 and x2.
But anyway, I can always
write the interference
of two waves like this.
So wave one and wave
two, it's negative square
is going to be i0 and 1 plus m
cosine, the phase difference.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SE BAEK OH: We are assuming
monochromatic, yes.
I mean, you can write--
[INAUDIBLE] we use
assuming monochromatic
because we're using
phase notation.
So we write this
and we write phaser,
but actually, there is e
to the i or negative i.
So yeah, we assume
it's monochromatic.
But even though
it's not chromatic,
you can always write just
addition of two waves.
It really doesn't matter.
So interference is basically
the dc term which is i0.
So i0 is actually a1
squared plus a2 squared,
which is intensity of wave
1 and intensity of wave 2.
So dc term is just
addition of the intensity,
and we have some
cosine modulation term.
So this is basically
interference.
So if we have coherent light,
then we have some dc term,
and have a sinusoidal
modulation.
And as the phase
varies, we're going
to see the sinusoidal
pattern is changing.
But remember that this optical
frequency is very fast--
like tens of
gigahertz [INAUDIBLE]..
So actually, what we measure--
I mean, intensity is
time average of this guy.
So we're going to take the
time average of intensity.
And if you do the math--
actually, we have the
dc term and this kind
of modulation term, which
is time average of cosine
with a phase difference.
But remember that if we
have incoherent light,
this phase difference is random.
So what is the average of
cosine of random phase?
[INAUDIBLE]
What is the average of
cosine or random phase?
AUDIENCE: Q.
SE BAEK OH: Yeah, Q.
Cosine is oscillating
between plus 1 and to minus 1.
So if you have random phase
and average, then you get 0.
So if you have incoherent
light, then basically intensity
is just addition of--
the intensity of 2
waves, and we don't
have any interference term.
So that's the difference between
coherent and incoherent light.
So coherent light, you always
have a modulation term.
I mean, it could be 0
depending on phase difference.
But in [INAUDIBLE],, you always
have just addition of dc term--
I mean addition of intensity.
So if it's perfectly
incoherent, then we
have just addition of intensity.
And actually, coherent
and incoherent is very--
actually two opposite
extreme cases.
So it's just like monochromatic.
In real case, we are
not going to have
really monochromatic source.
Our source is always
finite bandwidth.
It's not going to
be delta function.
So it's same thing.
We are not going to have the
perfectly coherent or perfectly
incoherent.
Everything is
partially coherent.
So if you want to deal with
it, then you have to apply
basically statistics to all
these Fresnel and [INAUDIBLE]----
I mean, this kind of
[INAUDIBLE] optics.
So it's called
statistical optics,
and it's covered in 2.707.
So if you want to
learn more about it,
then you can take 2.7 or 1.7.
But nevertheless, the
coherent and incoherent case
are enough to describe
many, many phenomena.
So we are focused on coherent
and incoherent state detection.
Going a little bit fast.
So-- oops.
Sorry.
So since we have two
kinds of coherence-- so
temporal coherence
and spatial coherence.
So actually, we have four
different combinations.
So temporarily and
spatially coherent,
and temporarily/spatially
incoherent.
And temporal incoherent,
spatially coherent, temporarily
coherent, spatially incoherent.
So the rule of thumb--
so temporal coherence is
related to the bandwidth
of your source--
basically, the color
of your source.
So if you have one color in
monochromatic, then it's--
question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, where do
diode lasers go in that chart?
SE BAEK OH: Diode laser
is more like temporally
and spatially coherent.
So yeah, let me just continue.
So temporal coherence
is related to color.
So if you have laser, like
single-color monochromatic,
then it's more like coherent.
But if you have white light,
like this fluorescent lamp
or halogen lamp,
then it's broadband,
so it's temporally incoherent.
And spatial coherence is
related to actually the size
of the source and the distance.
So everything coming
from the point source
is spatially coherent
because they're basically
coming from the same point.
But if your source
is extended like--
or you have the
filament in a bulb,
or this kind of
fluorescent light,
then it's spatially incoherent.
So the monochromatic
laser source,
laser is very monochromatic,
and the output is very small.
So laser is typically very
temporarily and spatially
incoherent, and that's
why people use it
in interferometry.
And white light source--
and if you are nearby
the white light source,
then it's more like temporally
and spatially incoherent.
And actually, these two are
a little bit interesting.
So temporally incoherent
or spatially coherent.
So if you put a small pinhole
in front of the white light,
then it's temporally incoherent
because it's broadband,
but it's coming from a pinhole,
so it's spatially coherent.
At the same reason, the sunlight
is very spatially coherent,
but temporally incoherent.
But the sun is very huge, but
also the distance is very huge.
So if you see the
sun, then it looks--
sunlight is coming
from point source,
so that's why it's
spatially coherent.
And yeah, the light from--
yeah, press the button, please.
It doesn't work?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But anyway, so one of the
things that [INAUDIBLE]
to measure coherence,
but what exactly
is coherent [INAUDIBLE]?
SE BAEK OH: Yeah, that
is a good question.
So actually, it's a little
bit lengthy to explain,
but what essentially the light--
I mean, this kind of light,
it excites some atoms.
And when they are going
down, you get the energy.
Basically, light
energy by e to the--
I mean energy is H mu.
But it's not--
I mean, this kind of spontaneous
emission is not correlated.
You have many, many atoms,
but they are not synchronized.
They are emitting randomly.
So basically, you
have some finite--
there are wave train.
So in that wave train, you
get basically coherent.
But you have many, many of
them with the random phase.
That's why you
add them together,
then you get incoherent.
So coherent length
is essentially
what is the length of
a finite wave train
that you can define
deterministic phase.
So d1-- so in just imagine
the Michelson interferometer,
you have the optical
path first, d1 minus d2.
But that difference is
within the distance,
then you get interference.
That's why you call the
coherence length and coherence
time.
And yeah, essentially,
that's it.
So remember that if we had--
AUDIENCE: Excuse me.
SE BAEK OH: Yep?
AUDIENCE: Here I also
will have one question.
So I want to check whether
this understanding is correct.
So let's say if the light
comes at a perfect parallel
direction, even though they
have different wavelengths,
it's considered
especially coherent.
And even if light go into
different directions,
but [INAUDIBLE] perfect--
the single wavelength, they're
considered time coherent.
Is this understanding correct?
SE BAEK OH: So actually,
if you have plain wave,
then you already assume your
wave is spatially coherent.
Because plane wave, it doesn't
really matter where you sample.
They have always same phase.
So your assumption
is spatially coherent
if you assume spatially
coherent light.
AUDIENCE: You mean even if they
have different wavelengths?
SE BAEK OH: Yeah.
Even though you have
different wavelengths,
that's temporally incoherent.
But in space domain, you
have spatially coherent.
Another way to think
of spatially incoherent
is you have many, many
plane waves propagating
all the different directions,
but they are randomly--
they have random initial phase.
So especially in coherent
light, you cannot really define
a unique propagation direction.
But spatially
coherent light, you
can always define direction.
Even though spherical wave
it has all the directions,
but you can always say--
if you put-- if you define the
position, then that position,
you have a k vector.
So you can define the direction.
So let me just
finish this thing.
So if d1 and d2 are within the
coherence length or coherence
time, then you get
some interference.
But after that--
so basically, this
is essentially the
coherence length
of this particular source.
And remember that--
I mean, this always happens.
So even though you
have a white light,
you can get interference, but
within a very limited range.
Where did I stop?
[CLEARS THROAT]
Excuse me.
So another interesting
thing is there
is a laser that has a broadband
which is [INAUDIBLE] laser.
So it's spatially coherent,
but it's broadband,
so you have temporally
incoherence.
And the other kind
of this combination
is temporally coherent, but
it's spatially incoherent.
And it's typically referred
to as quasi-monochromatic--
temporally coherent and
spatially incoherent.
So if you put a
rotating diffuser, which
is when you rotate the ground
glass or milky glass in front
of the laser, then basically,
it induces some random phase
to the laser beam where
we can say it destroyed
the correlation of the related.
So it's monochromatic,
so it temporally coheres.
But in space domain,
it is a random phase,
so you can have the
spatially incoherent light.
So these are a list of
optical instruments using
spatial coherence on imaging.
The Michelson stellar
interferometer and the radio
telescope, they are basically
measuring spatial coherence
of the light coming from a
distant star, or sun, or--
yeah, they're basically
for astronomy.
So they can measure,
for example,
the diameter of a distant star.
Remember, the
spatial coherence is
related to the source
size and the distance.
So if you properly measure
spatial coherence--
actually, the envelope
of the spatial coherence,
then you can estimate
the diameter of the star.
I believe Michelson got
a Nobel Prize for this.
And optical coherence
tomography is actually
utilizing temporal incoherence.
So as I just described, even
though you have white light,
if you properly match the
optical path difference,
then you can get interference
within a very small range.
So let's say you have
multiple layers like tissue,
and you construct the
Michelson interferometer
with the white light, and as
you move the other mirror,
then if the optical
path difference matches,
then you get interference.
But if you slightly
off that point,
then you don't get
the interference.
So if you plot the interference
versus the distance
of the mirror, then you
can see kind of the peak
whenever you have the right
position at each layer.
So you can kind of do
the optical sectioning.
And in the lithography
replication technique,
people use some
spatial coherence
to basically make
some nice pattern.
Because as we described
spatial coherence
is essentially affecting
this resolution
and the contrast of your image.
So there are these
kind of things
Even though we deal with
the spatially coherent
with the first system, so what
if we change the illumination
to a spatially incoherent
or temporally incoherent?
And obviously, my image
will be different depending
on the coherent state.
Actually, that's the bottom
line of today's lecture.
So first, if we have the
temporal incoherent--
basically, if you have
the broadband for many,
many colors--
then the chromatic aberration
is typical evidence
that I have temporal
incoherent source.
Then how to deal with it if
you have many, many colors?
That's pretty straightforward.
So you can define point spread
function, or ATF, or out--
or whatever it is.
You can define that thing
for each wavelength.
So for example, if I can
define point spread function
for red wavelength, I can
for blue wavelengths.
So it's just--
I can do with a
straightforward equation.
And spatial coherence
is a little bit--
and you need to be careful.
So the bottom-- actually,
this is the take-home message
of the lecture.
If the illumination
is spatially coherent,
then input field is
conversion of the-- actually,
output field is a
convolution of input field
with a coherent point spread
function, as we all know.
But if the illumination
is spatially incoherent,
then output intensity,
not the output field.
So output intensity
is a convolution
of the input intensity with
the incoherent point spread
function.
So that's the-- which means
if you have spatial coherent
illumination, then--
fields are linear systems.
You can do the
convolution in field.
But if the illumination
is incoherent,
then intensity is
a linear system,
so you can deal with the
intensity with the convolution.
So rest of the
lecture, we are going
to deal with the spatial
incoherent illumination.
So how we can define point
spread function, and transfer
function, and et cetera.
So first, let's review what
we have learned so far.
So we have fourth
system with a two length
whose focal lengths
are f1 and f2.
And typically, we put
our input transparency
grating at the input plane.
And we illuminate with the
spatially coherent illumination
and also temporally coherent.
So the input field just
right after the input
transparency is going to be just
a product of the illumination
field and the
complex transparency.
That's the input field.
And you're going to take
the Fourier transform to get
the field at the wave plane.
And another Fourier transform,
you get the final image.
And from that, we all know
that amplitude [INAUDIBLE]
function is nothing but
the [INAUDIBLE] function
with the coordinate scaling.
So ATF, H of u
[INAUDIBLE] some constant
and [INAUDIBLE] mask function,
and lambda f1u and lambda f1v.
And the point spread
function in field
is just Fourier
transform of the ATF.
Or you can say it's field
transform [INAUDIBLE] function.
So this is the coherent
point spread function.
And you can define [INAUDIBLE]
function reduce coordinate.
And the relation between
input and output field
is this convolution.
So G output-- I
mean, output field
is convolution of
input field, and this
is coherent point
spread function
which is defined in field.
So this is the stuff
that we all know.
So the next thing is let me put
the two pinholes at the input
plane.
And illuminate with the
spatially coherent light.
So basically, we have
Young interferometer here,
and I'm going to
image that pattern.
And since it is coherent--
it is illuminated
with the coherent light.
So essentially, I have--
at the image plane,
there's actually two
point spread functions
coming from two pinholes.
So in the upper
image is actually
coming from the lower
pinhole, and the lower image
actually coming from
the top pinhole.
But I have the addition
of two point spread
functions which is shifted
by the position of the two
pinholes.
And I may have some initial
phase, a1, e to the phi 1,
and a to--
e to the phi 2.
But the bottom line
is in coherent case,
I just have coherent
addition of two point spread
functions like this.
And to get the intensity,
as you all know,
we just take the negative
square of the sum,
and if we expand it,
then we have [INAUDIBLE]
which is the intensity
of the first point spread
function and intensity of the
second point spread function.
And we have some additional
modulation term, which
means I have some interference.
So it's a1, a2, and
rear path of this guy.
But rear path is always cosine.
So if you change the phase, you
have some sinusoidal modulation
term.
So this is sometimes
called interference term
or [INAUDIBLE] term.
It implies that you
have interference.
So with these parameters--
so initial phase
is just d to the
negative pi over 3,
and the other one is
the positive pi over 3.
Then if I plot this
intensity, then I'm
going to have this blue line.
So this is the case of
spatially coherent illumination.
And next, let's
suppose I illuminate
with the incoherent
illumination.
So as I described
earlier, the difference
between incoherent
and coherent is
I don't have interference
term if I illuminate
with the incoherent source.
So at the intensity, I
only have these two terms--
just intensity of
the first point
spread function and intensity
of the second point spread
function.
And I don't have the
extra cosine term.
So this is just intensity.
So if I plot the intensity
with the same parameter,
then this is how it looks.
And if I put together,
then the upper left
is the two intensity profiles
for coherent and incoherent
illumination.
So they are slightly different.
And if I play with a
different parameter,
like the different
initial phase.
And in this case, my
point spread function
has extra linear
phase term, then
the difference is
quite dramatic.
So you always have to be
careful what kind of coherence
your illumination is.
Any questions?
So in previous case, which
is spatially coherent,
then the input field and
output field is linear,
so you can use the convolution.
But in spatially
incoherent case,
we deal with the input
intensity which is--
so we're going to deal with
the input intensity and output
intensity.
And at the image
plane, the intensity
will be [INAUDIBLE]
incoherently.
So I illuminate
with the intensity--
I mean, incoherent illumination
with the intensity [INAUDIBLE],,
and g sub t is the
complex transparency.
But this is field, so you
have to take negative square.
So product of this guy is
basically your input intensity.
So this is illumination
intensity and--
intensity of your grating--
and this is point spread
function-- actually,
coherent point
spread function where
you take the negative
square because you
take the negative
square to get intensity.
[CLEARS THROAT] Excuse me.
We define incoherent
point spread function,
which is ipsf--
it's actually negative square
over the coherent point spread
function.
It's pretty simple, right?
You have point spread
function in field.
And if you just
take the intensity
and test the intensity
point spread function.
But you probably already
noticed the difference.
So if you use the
coherent illumination,
then the fields are
related to convolution,
but in coherent
case, intensities
are related to convolution,
and point spread function
are different.
Any questions?
I'm going to [INAUDIBLE].
So we just defined the
intensity point spread function,
which is negative square
coherent point spread function.
And by analogy, I mean
in the coherence case,
we had the coherent
point spread function.
And if you take the Fourier
transform of the coherent point
spread function,
then that is ATF--
amplitude transfer function.
So we could define the
same transform function
for incoherent point spread
function, which is OTF here.
So [INAUDIBLE] says that--
so actually, the small h is the
coherent point spread function,
and the capital H is ATF.
So they are a Fourier
transform pair.
And hI, which is intensity
point spread function,
is the negative square of the
coherent point spread function.
But hI and OTF which
is this weird h,
they are also a
Fourier transform pair.
So if you go through
this derivation,
then it will prove
actually they are--
that OTF is actually
this integration of ATF.
So once you have ATF, and after
you compute this information,
then you get OTF which
is auto correlation.
And I'm going to derive
in a different way here.
[INAUDIBLE] please.
So we start with hI of x,
which is intensity point spread
function is negative square
of the coherent point spread
function.
And-- yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you
write much bigger?
[INAUDIBLE]
SE BAEK OH: All right.
[LAUGHS]
Let me try.
That's too big, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHS]
SE BAEK OH: It's too small?
OK.
A little bit smaller.
We start with this
thing, and we know
that the OTF is Fourier
transform of intensity point
spread function.
And I can just plug into here.
So it's Fourier transform
of negative square
of the coherent point spread
function and Fourier transform.
And since it is
complex conjugate,
I can write as h of x.
And it's complex conjugate.
And since these
two are products,
then I can write as
convolution of two guys.
So it's Fourier
transform of h of x,
conversion with
Fourier transform
of a complex
conjugate like this.
[INAUDIBLE]
And Fourier transform of
the H is actually H of u--
I mean this guy.
ATF is just nothing but Fourier
transform of the coherent point
spread function.
And what about this guy?
Fourier transform of complex
conjugate of small h.
So I can write this
in integral form.
So integral h, complex
conjugate of x.
e to the minus j2pi, xu, dx.
And since it is
complex conjugate,
I can write as
integral h of x, e
to the I2pi xu, dx,
x, and conjugate.
So I can write as OTF
is H of u convolution,
and complex conjugate of
Fourier transform of--
like this.
Actually, [INAUDIBLE] transform.
So actually, this inverse
Fourier transform,
if you remember, the difference
of the Fourier transform
is actually integral h of
x, e to the I2pi xu, dx.
But
You can write as h of x, e to
the minus 2pi x minus u, dx.
So actually, it is Fourier
transform, and h of x.
But you change the
spatial frequency variable
as a minus u, So it's
going to be H of minus u.
So at the end, we have
H of u convolution,
and complex conjugate of--
ah, sorry.
H complex conjugate of minus u.
[INAUDIBLE] where I can
write as an integral form.
Integration H of u
prime, H of minus u
minus u prime, complex
conjugate, and du prime.
So essentially, integration
H complex conjugate--
sorry.
So I have H of u prime,
complex conjugate u prime minus
u, du prime, which
is essentially
this guy in [INAUDIBLE].
And sometimes, we denote by
H of u [INAUDIBLE] H of u,
which is auto-correlation.
Any questions on the derivation?
So before we move
on, can anyone guess
what this integration means?
So you have-- you want
to compute the OTF, which
is auto-correlation of the ATF.
But this integration is
basically you have H,
and you take the
complex conjugate,
but you shift and
take the integral.
So next slide, I'm going to
explain how we can compute--
so bottom line of
this slide is OTF
is nothing but
auto-correlation of your ATF.
But next slide is
how to compute when--
you can simply compute
this integration,
but there is another easy
way to guess the OTF.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SE BAEK OH: Conceptually, yes.
I mean, actually,
Fourier transform
of the input intensity and
Fourier transform of the output
intensity, and the
ratio of [INAUDIBLE]..
So let's first compute the
OTF for the simple case.
I have the rectangular aperture
in my [INAUDIBLE] plane.
And from that, I
know that the ATF--
H of u-- is just [INAUDIBLE]
function, and u over umx.
So umx is defined
by the physical size
of the [INAUDIBLE] function.
And so if it's just
x, double prime x,
and with the scaling
vector of lambda F1.
So this is the ATF.
And I just put that OTF is
auto-correlation of ATF.
In integral form, I
have this integration.
So let's just take a look at
this [INAUDIBLE] actually.
So OTF is function of u,
but this integration--
I mean inside of
this integration,
I have function of H of u prime.
And H complex conjugate,
u prime minus u.
So I have the first
function, which
is essentially same as
my original function
even though I change the
variable from u to u prime.
But this guy is function of
u prime where you shift by u.
And [INAUDIBLE] integration.
And this whole thing
is function of u,
which means you're
going to compute
this integration for every
u, and then you get OTF.
And this integration
is basically
you have two functions,
one is shifted by u,
and multiply them, and
take the integration, which
is essentially you compute
the overlapped area of the two
functions.
So graphically, if I have
[INAUDIBLE] function and plug
it in this integration,
I have this integration.
But I can imagine for
a different situation,
the first--
so this [INAUDIBLE] function
is the coherent [INAUDIBLE]
function.
And the second one
which is moving
is a coherent
[INAUDIBLE] function.
So if they are not
overlapped, then I
get simply 0 the
first situation.
And as soon as they
are overlapped,
and then the overlapped area
is getting linearly increased.
So I get this u plus umx until
they are completely overlapped.
And then-- so this
is [INAUDIBLE]----
and then once you move
a little bit further,
then basically this overlapped
area is getting decreased.
So this is third situation,
which is this guy.
And eventually, they are
not going to overlap,
so I get 0 again.
Remember that this OTF
is functional of u,
which is the amount of shift
of this [INAUDIBLE] function.
Any questions?
So if you plot this
overlapped area--
I mean this guy and this guy--
with respect to u,
then actually we
are going to get a
triangular function, which
looks like this one.
And of course, we normalize
at the 0 frequency.
So at the 0, we always have a 1.
So you notice the difference
between these two.
So ATF-- my ATF is nothing
but my [INAUDIBLE] function--
just left function.
And the color frequency,
umx, is defined
by my physical size
of the [INAUDIBLE]
with the scaling factor.
But OTF is auto-correlation,
so the shape
is now the triangular shape.
But also the color frequency--
the umx is twice of the umx,
because basically you go
through all this process.
So you get twice of
the color frequency.
So-- yeah?
Oh.
So whatever
[INAUDIBLE] you have,
if you compute this
kind of overlapped area,
then you can get OTF.
So [INAUDIBLE] you have a
rectangular square aperture,
then you if you go through
this auto-correlation,
then you can get
this kind of OTF.
So this is just completely
linear in u and [INAUDIBLE]
direction.
Again, the fx and fy,
they are [INAUDIBLE]..
And if you have the circular
aperture, it's almost linear,
but it's slightly
curved at the edge.
But essentially, they
are the same thing.
So if you move
around two circles
in completely overlapped
area, then you
end up with this function.
I guess this is a good
time to take a break.
Any questions so far?
So we discussed there
is a lot of difference
between temporal and
spatial coherence,
and defined the intensity
point spread function,
and also defined
the OTF which is
Fourier transform with
the intensity point spread
function.
And at the last--
[CLEARS THROAT] excuse me--
OTF is auto-correlation
of the ATF.
And I visually showed
how to compute the OTF.
So let's just summarize
what we discussed so far.
So first, we all know that
coherent point spread function
is nothing but an optical
field generated by a point
source at [INAUDIBLE] plane.
And that's the field.
And also you know that
coherent point spread function
is Fourier transform
[INAUDIBLE] function
with a coordinate scaling.
And incoherent point
spread function
is negative square of
coherent point spread.
Or another way to say
is intensity point
spread function is intensity of
the field coherent point spread
function.
And we define the amplitude
[INAUDIBLE] function, ATF,
which is Fourier transform
of the coherent point spread
function.
And it is nothing but the
[INAUDIBLE] function with
the scaling vector--
I mean coordinate scaling.
And we just derive
the OTF, which
is Fourier transform of the
intensity point spread function
is actually auto-correlation
with the ATF.
In the rest of
the lecture, we're
going to mostly deal
with the MTF which
is negative modulus of the OTF.
Actually, it should be OTF.
So MTF is the negative
component of OTF.
In terms of input
and output, we're
dealing with a linear
system approach.
So if you have the spatially
coherent illumination--
so [INAUDIBLE] is the
illumination field.
And I have the
thin transparency--
the complex transparency
which is sub t.
Then my input field is just
product of my illumination
field and complex transparency.
So g sub n, that's
the input field.
And if I convert with the
coherent point spread function,
that's going to be my output
field, which is g sub f.
And I kind of think this whole
thing in frequency domain.
So if I take a
Fourier transform--
[INAUDIBLE] is actually
Fourier transform
of small gn, which is Fourier
component of my input field.
And convolution
is multiplication
in frequency domain.
So I multiply by ATF, then
I'm going to get g sub--
[INAUDIBLE] which is Fourier
inform of my output field.
And if I have the spatially
incoherent illumination,
then I deal with the intensity.
So I have the intensity
of illumination, and I--
still complex transparency.
So actually, my input intensity
is illumination intensity
times negative
square of g sub t.
So remember that gt is
complex transparency.
So to make intensity, you
have to take negative square.
So this is my input intensity.
And in current case,
it's linear in intensity,
so you have to convert with
the intensity point spread
function, which is negative
square of the coherent point
spread function.
Then you're going to
get in output intensity.
And again, in the
frequency domain,
we can take the Fourier
transform-- so g sub i--
what can I say?
Character gi input--
character g sub i in,
which is Fourier transform
of the input intensity.
And you're going
to multiply by OTF,
which is what
auto-correlation of the ATF.
And you'll get the
Fourier transform
of the output intensity.
So actually, if you're familiar
with the control theory,
then you probably
know the Bode plot.
So Bode plot is
nothing but you have--
in frequency domain, it
describes the weighting
function that is going to
be multiplied by your input
and produce your output.
So this ATF, and
OTF, and also MTF,
they are basically
the same thing.
You multiply your--
so basically,
this transform function
in frequency domain
describes the
weighting function here
that is going to be
multiplied by your input.
And you can just compare the--
and also another way to say
it is the ratio between input
and output.
So MTF-- so, yeah.
So as I described,
this transform function
is nothing but with weighting
function in frequency domain.
So let me show
you how to use it.
Because if you buy a lens
for your digital camera--
I mean, typically
the SLR camera--
so lets make us
provide the MTF layer,
which is this weighting function
with the spatial frequency,
and with the color frequency.
It's cool-- you can say
what kind of image quality
I can expect with the lens.
So first, let's consider
our [INAUDIBLE] grating
whose MTF transform function
is given by this equation.
So the input intensity
is going to be--
I mean intensity of the grating
is going to be negative square,
so I add 1 over 2.
Then 1 plus n modulation,
and cosine term.
And the phase
[INAUDIBLE] it doesn't
matter why, because if you
take a negative square,
it's always 1.
The Fourier transform of
this input intensity is--
we all know that it
has three 3 orders.
So 0-th order, and the 1 over
capital lambda, and minus 1
over capital lambda.
We have three different orders.
And it's going to be multiplied
by the OTF, which is at this h.
And since this is delta
function, which means
this one is 1 only
at u equals 0,
and when u equals 1
over capital lambda,
and at minus 1 capital lambda.
So if you multiply the OTF--
and actually, you still
have the three components.
So at 0 component, you have
the OTF at the 0 frequency.
And these two delta functions
are multiplied by OTF
at the 1 over capital lambda
and minus 1 over capital lambda.
We still have the three
[INAUDIBLE] orders.
And let me just go back.
So since this is your Fourier
transform of the output
intensity, you can
just take the inverse
Fourier transform to compute
the output intensity, right?
But there is another--
there is an important
property of the OTF.
So this guy and this guy.
So OTF is actually--
intensity point spread
function, which is h sub i,
is negative square of the
coherent point spread function.
So it is always positive--
it's non-negative I should say.
So it's non-negative.
So this Fourier
transform is actually
Hermitian, which
mathematically, you
can [INAUDIBLE] h of
minus u-- is actually
h complex conjugate of u.
Or you can say its real path
is [INAUDIBLE] function,
but its simulated
path is out function.
So OTF of the physically
realizable optical system
must be Hermitian.
So this condition should
be satisfied always.
So in the previous
slide, I had--
let me just--
[INAUDIBLE]
Capital G, I, out, was 1
over 2 OTF at 0, and delta u.
Plus n over 2, H, 1 over
capital lambda, and delta u,
1 over capital lambda.
Plus H minus 1 over
capital lambda,
delta u, 1 over capital lambda.
Since the OTF is Hermitian,
which means my OTF over minus 1
over capital lambda is
actually complex conjugate
of H, 1 over capital lambda.
This is Hermitian.
So G out--
I mean, the capital G, I, out,
I can write as 1 over 2 OTF at 0
is still delta function.
And m over 2, H, 1 over
capital lambda, delta u,
1 over capital lambda.
But the last delta
function I can
write as H complex conjugate,
1 over capital lambda, decay u
plus 1 over capital lambda.
So the first delta function--
I mean, if you take the inverse
Fourier transform [INAUDIBLE]
transform, the first delta
function [INAUDIBLE]----
just 1 or something.
So it's pretty straightforward.
The question is still what
happened in these two delta
functions, because
this one has H of--
I mean the OTF at one
over capital lambda,
and the other one is
actually complex conjugate.
So if I just write the
two delta function part,
and I'm going to take the
inverse Fourier transform.
So inverse Fourier transform,
or m over 2, [INAUDIBLE]
OTF at 1 over capital lambda,
delta u, 1 over capital lambda,
plus H complex conjugate,
capital lambda, delta u plus 1
over capital lambda.
Then what is-- inverse
Fourier transform [INAUDIBLE]
function is going
to be exponential.
And [INAUDIBLE] do we scale it?
So [INAUDIBLE] just outside.
And I'm going to have H
of 1 over capital lambda,
and exponent e to the I2pi,
x over capital lambda,
plus H complex conjugate,
1 over capital lambda.
e to the minus I2pi,
x over capital lambda.
And I can write as
capital lambda--
1 over capital lambda, e
to the I2pi, x over lambda.
Plus-- actually the same thing--
H, 1 over capital lambda, e
to the I2pi, x over lambda.
And complex conjugate like this.
So what happens if you add
A and its complex conjugate?
So for example, this is A, and
this is A complex conjugate.
And if you add them
together, then you
get only rear path, because
two rear paths over A.
So then I'm going to have
m, the rear path of OTF
at 1 over capital lambda,
to the I2pi x over lambda,
which I can write
as m, and negative--
this H is just non-zero.
So it could have--
I mean, it can have only 0 or
minus [INAUDIBLE] basically.
So I can write it
as negative here.
And this [INAUDIBLE]
cosine 2pi, x over lambda.
So that's why the output
intensity is just 1
plus m, which is
original modulation.
But I add extra modulation
due to OTF and cosine term.
Should I prove why
OTF is Hermitian?
Yeah, let me prove
why OTF is Hermitian.
So OTF is auto-correlation
of ATF, which is like this.
And integration with the
integral form I can write as H
of u prime, H complex
conjugate, u prime minus u,
and [INAUDIBLE] prime.
And how to compute H--
I mean OTF and complex
conjugate of u.
So I can write as--
the total thing--
H of u prime, H complex
conjugate u prime u, u prime,
and complex conjugate.
AUDIENCE: Excuse me.
SE BAEK OH: Yes?
AUDIENCE: We're not able to
see what you are writing.
SE BAEK OH: Oh, it's too small?
AUDIENCE: OK now.
SE BAEK OH: So I just
take the complex conjugate
on both sides.
And I can chain the
complex conjugate.
So it's going to be H complex
conjugate of u prime, H,
and u prime and u, and du prime.
So I just put the
complex conjugate inside
of the integration.
And here, I define
the new variable.
So u double prime
is u prime minus u.
So u prime is u
plus u double prime.
And du prime is actually
du double prime.
So this H complex
conjugate is actually
H complex conjugate,
u plus u double prime,
h of u double
prime, and du double
prime, which I can write as
integration h u double prime.
A complex conjugate u
double prime, minus u,
du double prime.
So it's H of minus u.
So this is complex
conjugate Hermitian.
I just proved you
can easily do that.
So then the bottom line
is at the output plane--
I mean output intensity,
I have extra modulation
coming from the OTF.
I mean, you can say
intensity is negative,
so you can say [INAUDIBLE].
So if you compare in terms of
the contrast or visibility,
so the contrast is
defined by imx minus ime
over imx plus ime.
But at the output plane, we
have the extra modulation term.
So if you compute
the same thing,
then actually your
contrast is going
to be at the original
modulation multiplied by MTF
at the spatial frequency.
So MTF is just contrast
at the spatial frequency
relative to the transmission
that we're discussing.
So what does it mean?
So for example, I have
MTF looks like this.
And I initially
had the grating--
the intensity of the grating
is actually 1 over 2,
1 plus n, cosine, 2pi,
x over capital lambda.
So if I draw in grayscale-- so
the white is 1 and black is 0.
So I have nice sinusoid with
a full contrast like this.
But the output
intensity, I'm going
to have 1 plus m, and additional
modulation, and cosine term.
And this factor, you
can find [INAUDIBLE]..
So if you have the 1
over capital lambda,
then you can find the
value at that point--
I mean MTF at this point.
So if that value is
0.6 in this case,
this sinusoidal pattern
will look like this.
But if the modulation is
0.2, then the black becomes
brighter and white
becomes darker.
So you kind of get
the grayscale--
[INAUDIBLE] version of
the gradient like this.
So basically, this MTF tells
you what kind of contrast
I expect at this particular
spatial frequency,
and also it specifies the
maximum spatial frequency
you can resolve--
I mean, you can see.
Any questions?
So so far, we just
deal with the idea
of thin lens with
a clear aperture,
like the rectangular
aperture is a clear aperture.
So in the case of the
rectangular aperture,
we know that the OTF is just
auto-correlation of the two
[INAUDIBLE] functions which
is just triangular function.
So it's linear from
1 to color frequency,
which is twice of the
[INAUDIBLE] frequency at OTF--
the ATF.
And if you have the
circular aperture,
it's almost linear
except at the [INAUDIBLE]
you have slightly curved line.
But it's the same thing.
So this blue line and the
black line we call defraction
limited OTF, because we
assume the idea of a thin lens
without any aberration.
So this is kind of best
OTF you can achieve.
But in practice, you
always have aberration--
chromatic aberration,
or any high aberration.
Or you can have a defocus, or
some imperfect factor in lens.
So typically, the
typical lens has
this kind of distorted or
degraded OTF like this.
The red one right here or here.
So in terms of this
defraction limited,
you want to buy a lens that OTF
is similar to this blue line,
because this is
defraction limited,
which means the best
OTF we can achieve.
And [INAUDIBLE].
So I describe-- I mean,
this is slope is linear,
and circular aperture.
I mean, locally, it can
have a higher value,
but the overall shape should
be smaller than this blue line.
So let's just apply all these
concepts in [INAUDIBLE] system.
So we have first system
whose focal length f1, f2.
And I put the
input transparency,
which is a binary [INAUDIBLE]
grading right here.
And illuminate with the
quasi-monochromatic which
is on a single color,
and spatial [INAUDIBLE]
illumination, and [INAUDIBLE] we
assume the intensity variation
is uniform.
So the possible question
is what kind of image
we can expect at the image
plane, or what is the OTF,
or what is ATF, and
blah, blah, blah.
So let's go through it.
So this is the binary
amplitude grating.
So it is still complex
transparency in here.
So if you have
[INAUDIBLE] illumination,
you want to compute
the intensity.
So you have to take
the negative scale.
So this is just 0 or 1,
so basically you have
the same thing in intensity.
So that's the input
intensity at the upper right.
And this is the phase mask
located at the rear plane.
And we know that the ATF is
basically the same function
with different coordinates.
So ATF is phase mask,
but the function
is the x double
prime-- well, I mean
you have this coordinate
scaling vector.
So if you compute the
OTF from this ATF,
basically, what you do is you
have two [INAUDIBLE] functions.
So you will have actually
4 [INAUDIBLE] functions.
And you move toward them,
so whenever they overlap,
you get some value.
So if could do the
auto-correlation,
then actually you're going
to have three triangular.
But remember, if you have
the [INAUDIBLE] function,
then you move two
[INAUDIBLE] function.
So you're going to
have one triangular.
So since we have two [INAUDIBLE]
functions, so whenever
they first [INAUDIBLE],, then
we have the one triangle.
But the second and the
two [INAUDIBLE] functions
overlap, then we have
the center triangle.
And like this, we
another triangle, so
we get three triangles.
So that's the OTF.
And if you expand with the
Fourier series of your input
intensity, then we're going
to have an infinite number
of diffraction.
But in ATF case, we
have only first order
and the minus first
order, and minus
first order going
to be transmitted.
But in OTF, actually,
they are blocked.
[INAUDIBLE]
Actually, plus 2,
and 0, and minus 2,
they are going to
be transmitted.
So you just multiply these
three delta functions
by the value of the ATF--
this, this, this.
And the Fourier transform
will be your output intensity,
which is this.
So 1 over 3 just came from the
central [INAUDIBLE] function,
because this is 1--
so just 1 over 3.
And for the first order,
at the 0.1 and minus 0.1
micrometer [INAUDIBLE],,
actually they have 0 value.
So I multiply by 0.
And for the second order,
I have one over 2 which
is this value here and here.
So that is the [INAUDIBLE]
of the output intensity.
So if you compute the
inverse Fourier transform
of this equation, then we
are going to have 1 over 3,
and 1 over 2, and
two exponent here
which is actually
cosine like this.
So in terms of
grayscale image, we
have the binary
amplitude grating,
which varies just black
or white like this.
But if you go through
this [INAUDIBLE] system
at the image, we're going to
have this kind of grayscale
because contrast is just 0.1034.
So it's very little.
And the average value is
about 0.33 or something.
So basically, it looks gray
with a little wiggling.
So ATF basically
tells you the contrast
of the particular
spatial frequency.
So, yeah.
What happened-- I mean,
the orders at this side.
So if my OTF is 0, then what
kind of image I can expect?
It's black?
It's not light, right?
So if it is 0--
I mean if the
values are 0, then--
so I still have [INAUDIBLE]
so some kind of grayscale.
So I don't see any [INAUDIBLE].
OTF is auto-correlation,
so you always
have 1 at the dc frequency.
Because if you move
the two functions,
so when they exactly
overlap, you always
have the maximum value.
So you always have
[INAUDIBLE] system.
And actually, that is very
different in current case.
So in ATF case, you can actually
cancel [INAUDIBLE] system,
right?
But OTF, you can not
cancel the system,
because it's auto-correlation.
So again, we have some
relation with the [INAUDIBLE]..
So this particular
circular aperture,
if I eliminate the
coherent illumination,
then this is the image--
AUDIENCE: Excuse me.
SE BAEK OH: Yes?
AUDIENCE: In Singapore
slide, the [INAUDIBLE] slides
are not [INAUDIBLE].
SE BAEK OH: Maybe
it takes time or--
AUDIENCE: No, it even didn't
show that input and output
image when you explained
about that contrast.
SE BAEK OH: Just let
me ask [INAUDIBLE]..
Hello, [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Yes?
SE BAEK OH: Yes, [INAUDIBLE].
It's frozen.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SE BAEK OH: I think they're
going to reset the system.
So let me just
take a few moments.
Any questions so far?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SE BAEK OH: So actually--
yeah?
AUDIENCE: What happens
when you [INAUDIBLE]??
SE BAEK OH: Actually, I'm
going to talk about it,
but in general, if you use
the incoherent light, then
you don't see any phase
effects because [INAUDIBLE]
the negative square.
So it doesn't really matter.
So you don't see any--
I mean, you barely
see some variation,
but usually it's not
dramatic as [INAUDIBLE]..
And what was I about to say?
Oh, yeah-- so MTF is just
magnitude of the OTF.
So we haven't talk about
any phase of the OTF.
So what's the effect of the--
I mean, what does
it mean if I have
some phase variation in OTF?
Can you guess?
So for example, OTF
is always non-zero.
It's always 0 or positive.
But its phase can be 0 or pi.
So what if I have pinhole
phase shift in OTF?
For example, I have sinusoidal
grating, and at the output
I have a sinusoidal grating.
But what does it mean I
have the pi phase shift?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SE BAEK OH: Not really.
What happens if
you shift by pi--
I mean if you move
to a cosine by pi?
You get sine.
So you have cosine pattern here.
And if you have pi
phase shift, then you
will have the sine
pattern, which
means you flip the black
and white of the image.
And I flip the [INAUDIBLE].
So I flip the-- but
still I [INAUDIBLE]
between the black and
white, not the sine/cosine.
[INAUDIBLE] can anybody see
the slide right now, or?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I have a question.
How do you introduce this
pi phase shift in OTF?
SE BAEK OH: So if you have
pi phase shift in OTF, then
basically you flip
the black and white.
So your input image is black--
let's say the black,
white, black, white.
And your image is going to be
white, black, white, black.
AUDIENCE: No, my
question is physically,
how do you introduce that
controllable phase shift
in OTF?
SE BAEK OH: So this
ATF can be complex.
So if you compute
the auto-correlation,
then actually, you can
have negative value of OTF.
And if you have
the negative value
in OTF, which means you have
still positive and negative,
but you have some negative--
I mean, basically pi phase.
So if you want to do
that kind of thing,
basically, you have some
complex transparency
at your [INAUDIBLE] mask.
But if you have clear aperture,
then you don't get that effect.
So let me continue this slide.
I mean, these three images we
already seen maybe two or three
lectures ago.
So this is MIT lecture--
I mean the image of MIT letters
with the coherent emission.
And the right two
images obtained
with the incoherent emission.
So I can notice two
main differences here.
So if I use the
[INAUDIBLE] emission,
basically, the
image looks sharper
than the one with the coherent.
And that's because
OTF has a higher--
twice of higher
color frequency even
though they get attenuated.
But basically, it can pass
through the higher spatial
frequency, so that's
why it preserves more
higher frequency--
preserves higher frequency.
And it's same thing here.
So with the coherent light,
you barely see the letter "I",
but you can still see the MIT.
And another difference is
actually if you see "M" or "T",
there are some variations,
like black or white.
Some wiggling in MIT here.
But in coherent case, the
intensity is more like uniform.
You don't see some
weird variation.
So that's another difference.
So here's the incoherent light.
So generally, you
don't have the ringing
artifact as I described,
and also no [INAUDIBLE]..
So you're not going to
see any interference.
And it is higher bandwidth
because the color frequency
is twice higher than the
color frequency in ATF.
So you can see the
smaller features--
I mean the two points closer.
You can see the smaller feature.
But as I answered to
[INAUDIBLE] question,
incoherent image is
insensitive to phase variation.
So mostly, we just deal with the
monochromatic, and especially
incoherent.
But if you have polychromatic,
which is broadband,
then you're going to have
some chromatic aberrations.
But again, you can define
all these OTF, or MTF,
or point spread functions for
each different wavelength.
So it just extends this in
a straightforward fashion.
It's the end of show,
so any questions?
So the take-home message
of this [INAUDIBLE] lecture
is if you have
coherent illumination,
then you have linear
convolution in field.
But if you have
incoherent case, and you
have the linear
relation in intensity,
and for incoherent
light, you have
to deal with the OTF, which
is auto-correlation of ATF.
And that's pretty much about it.
If you don't have questions,
then let's see next Monday.